hello i'm sanskrita
and i'm very interested in understanding
what makes or breaks or immune systems
cancer is one such question and hence my
topic
fun fact in the background of the slide
is an image of
pd1 expression and t cell surface as
seen by fluorescence microscope
we will discuss a little bit about the
pd1 receptors in the upcoming slides
so moving on
in the duration of the next few minutes
i will be speaking about immunotherapy
specifically immune checkpoint
inhibitors in the context of non-small
cell lung cancer and also discuss the
results of analysis of gene expression
during therapy
so first about non-small cell lung
cancer
or nsclc when we look at the diagnostic
and
mortality figures of cancer lung cancer
trumps all other types causing almost 20
percent of the deaths and non-small cell
lung cancer accounts for 90 percent of
these deaths
therefore a rigorous study of nsclc and
our therapeutic options are very
important
currently the doctors prefer surgical
resection and radiotherapy for early
stage patients
while chemotherapy is provided to late
stage patients
our last confirmed data packs nsclc
debts to a close
to a close 1.62 million clearly we need
improved therapeutic modalities
so immunotherapy
immunotherapy manipulates
the immune system's own effectors to
deal with these disease conditions i'm
going to focus more on the immune
checkpoint inhibitors here
so the receptors program death 1 or pd1
and cytotoxic t-cell associated protein
or ctla4 are expressed by almost all
types of t cells
dynamically across time and magnitude of
immune response
so in normal conditions they would
interact with their ligands on dendritic
cells and suppress the immune response
this forms the basis of autoimmunity
prevention which is essential but cancer
cells taking advantage of it also
express uh ligands pdl1 and b7 which can
help them to mute the immune response
when it is actually required
the interaction between pd1 and its
ligand sets off a cascade
it causes effector t cell dysfunction
exhaustion and neutralization of
maturity cells prevents further
activation of naive t cells and also can
activate the regulatory diesels
all these together produce a cytokine
brew that makes the tumor micro
environment highly inflamed
the tumor growth becomes more aggressive
and invasive gradually shutting down all
branches of immune system
so immune checkpoint inhibitors
interfere in the first step of this
process blocking any interaction between
the receptors and their ligands by
competitive binding to one or the other
even in the league of tumors nsclc shows
extremely high mutational burden so it
becomes very affable to this form of
intervention
the data that i have analyzed is tri
trial data of checkpoint inhibitor
nivolumab
it is a humanized antibody that binds
specifically to the receptor pd1
although it is theoretically a very
robust therapy many failures have been
observed in the form of adverse immune
events and or progressive disease
so the two questions i had going into
the study was whether genes expressed in
cytotoxic t cells
have any influence over the response
towards nivolumab therapy and if
administration of nivolumab influences
the gene expression in these cells so i
got the data set from jio and here is
the summary of the available information
so most of the patients had already
tried either surgery radiation or chemo
and did not see any improvement
so they were put on a course of
nivolumab and their serum samples
containing uh peripheral blood
mononuclear cells or lymphocytes
extracted before administration and six
to eight weeks after the administration
so before we move further a small point
needs clarity so response here refers
only to partial response throughout the
study in case of lung cancer
we generally can't hope for anything
better than that
now we can talk about the steps taken to
answer the questions i had
so the sequence reads uh were found to
be multiplexed and they had to be
demultiplexed before alignment and
mapping
boutique and are some expression table
algorithms on the t by info platform
were chosen for alignment mapping and
generating read counts
so
once the expression data was obtained in
expected counts genes that had low
average counts were eliminated before
performing further analysis
then based on the questions i wanted to
answer i created different groups of
data for exploratory analysis and
differential expression analysis
so on to the results of these analysis
starting with pca for exploratory
analysis
the first graph seen here is uh
for a general analysis of how the data
segregates based on expression values
this file contained information
regarding responders and non-responders
labeled at time points before and after
the administration of nivolumab
so the only
slightly clearer clustering is seen in
the violet dots on this side of the
graph
with one outlier here
and
these are from non-responders at the
final time point
this does not seem to be very useful
for us
and an outlier excluded pc analysis
could be performed but this data is
spared so excluding this outlier would
mean that we would have to explode
exclude some green point as well
this is a small patient group and this
does not seem to be a very optimal
solution
so i
went ahead and tried to analyze the
expression values as a whole at the
initial time points and final time
points and between responders and
non-responders with
no clear distinction again
to see if a new lumab influences
expression in killer t cells a large pc
analysis was performed for just the
response responders between initial and
final time point even this does not
provide any insights into the
relationship between expression values
and the known phenotypes however if we
look at the first uh three pca plots
this one and the first two in this page
we see that there is a very distinct
separation between the data points
right down the middle for reference
so this clustering is not explained by
any of the groups or definitions
provided by the data this points to some
missing sample information that could
help us understand the interaction
between nevolumab and cd8 positive t
cells better
but it's not available at the moment
now um on to the differential gene
expression analysis so the first
analysis was performed uh
between
responders and non-responders at time
point n1 to understand if gene
expression could somehow influence the
therapeutic response
here is a volcano plot
to represent the down regulation and up
regulation in genes with their
significance so to the left of the graph
are the down regulated genes and to the
right are the upregulated genes
lower negative
log p values indicate
low significance
and as we can see most of the genes have
a negative log p adjusted value of below
one
and the actual p adjusted value is very
high and upon a preliminary sorting of
the output table the smallest p adjusted
value came out to be 0.13 which is much
higher than the
preferred 0.5 threshold
so this finalizes the fact that
differential expression in responders
and non-responders before administration
of new lumab is
not significant enough and hence cannot
possibly influence the therapeutic
response
then
the second group of analysis
were the expression
in killer t-cells of respondents between
the initial and final time points we are
looking to see if nivolumab influences
the expression in its course of action
so one glance at the volcano plot shows
us that it does not by a lot but it does
only three significantly down regulated
genes were observed and these results
prevent us from moving ahead to analyze
pathways and gene ontology terms that
are differentially expressed
but
these three genes are also involved
heavily with many important cancer cell
deaths and immune response pathways
all of these genes
produce
long known non-coding rna and are
extremely essential in the regulation of
protein coding pathways although they
are unlikely to be translated themselves
so block one is transcript is uh shown
to be involved in two important pathways
and its down regulation is associated
with
silenced t cell factor four
t cell factor four uh proteins along
with other proteins of the tcf lef
family
are directly involved in inducing the
transcription of genes downstream of the
wnt pathway so the expression of these
genes influences t cell development and
differentiation at various time points
and tissue types like thymus lymph nodes
and tumor micro environment
these gene products can act in both
stimulatory and inhibitory ways
and a decrease in stimulation of wnt
signaling pathway improves naive cd8
positive t cell conversion into mature
cells and reduces fox p3 positive uh
transcriptional activity in
regulatory t cells
hence the down regulation of block 1s as
seen by the graph can deal with
effective t cell exhaustion and improve
t cell activation and reduce immune
suppression in the tumor micro
environment
so
tc4c silencing also directly improves
anti-tumor activity of
antigen presenting cells and thus can
help in delaying cancer growth
block 1s is also associated with
ferrotosis which is different from
apoptosis and necrosis it is a novel
cell death pathway and we won't be going
into the details regarding that however
proposals have been made to use genes
associated with ferrotosis as diagnostic
and prognostic markers in breast cancer
and a few other tumor types
so studies for its use in lung cancer
prognosis have not been conducted yet
but this could be a good starting point
and then coming to the next gene the
d7 uh tcam 2
could be
the whole locus near this gene is
associated with the tram trif pathway
a down regulation in the tme d70 cam 2
could be associated with reduced
inflammation
in tumor micro environment and this
could reduce the number of regulatory t
cells near tumors and further prevent
the conversion of helper t cells into
regulatory t cells for a bit of
clarification although the study
analyzes expression in cytotoxic t-cells
of adaptive system the responses of
adaptive and the innate system are
usually influenced by cells from either
of the systems in our body
so
yeah
anyway about the third gene
not a lot of information is available
about available about it for now
hopefully we'll be able to study how it
factors into all of this soon
now here's a recap of the questions
before we summarize the results
the pca plots show a distinct separation
undefined by available data there seems
to be some confounding variable
influencing the separation or based on
gene expression
and based on differential analysis gene
expression in tumor infiltrating
cytotoxic t cells cannot influence
response to nepolumab and cannot be used
as a marker for predicting the response
either
however
nivolumab does affect
gene expression in these cells and can
be used as a marker for analysis of
disease progression
i believe that integrating uh
other omics big data could give us
better results and find important
prognostic markers but the expression
library used also seems to
be a bit lacking
as we saw in the mechanism of pd1 action
inclusion of other cell types like
helper t cells and regulatory t cells
could possibly fill this gap
and
after some discussions the time duration
between measurement of response could be
one of the factors causing less
differential gene expression
like uh six to eight weeks between
response response measurement according
to resist guidelines apply for tumor
cells
the change in gene expression of t cells
precedes the tumor reduction that it
would mediate
so a few weeks before this time or
increasing the frequency of sample
extraction could improve the study
greatly
and
using different algorithms and
analytical tools is always an option
but
the probability of that alone improving
our results is very slim
so in conclusion
dealing with lung cancer is still not in
a stage where we can confidently look
for cures
the clinicians are currently focused on
controlling growth of tumor and a
palliative care
and immune checkpoint inhibitors show
promise on paper and also in many trials
but to make up for the dearth of
response use of combination therapies is
growing more popular and
the second regimen in the combination
therapy being
of chemotherapeutic agent like cisplatin
or other immune checkpoint blockers like
atazolizumab
or epillumab
so
the till these trials give us adequate
results tobacco eradication must be our
number one step against lung cancer that
is it for my report and i'd like to take
some time to thank my mentors and guides
dr raghav and sonalika mam for helping
me put this together and working through
this project thank you so much